order
oh cool I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to okay
I am excited I am so very excited today
we get to review the Alvin and the
Chipmunks movie oh my god I love this
film with this hair-raising adventures
singing new songs along with old ones
and traveling the world while escaping
danger around every turn it strange cuz
I swear a review this film before and a
crossover but that doesn't matter we are
looking at it today in all its glory and
I am psyched my friends and I haven't
seen this movie in years
wait wait you in green I'm coming
oh well Cheers let's get ready for this
awesome chipmunk adventure Oh shitty CGI
one Christ this is what people think of
when they hear the Chipmunks movie yes
sure with the movie making nut loads of
money at the box office we have cemented
ourselves as the only real chipmunks
franchise how are you able to keep
making these films yeah we know kids
will watch anything but who's taking
them new OC or even creep you're
watching it themselves simple a
demographic that never lets us down be
all girls the all girls women and teens
will watch anything simply to say oh ah
damn it your love of cuteness is ruining
a perfectly good franchise but they're
just so adorable
we're not here to analyze story we just
want to look at cute little animals do
cute little things oh I just want to
pitch their sheep ladies are ruining the
dignity of a great adventure series oh
really
isn't your movie about Chipmunks who
operate balloons for diamond smuggling
it made a lot of sense in the 80s more
than Eleanor not wearing green hey I'm
colorblind okay what me too
enough of that look our movie makes a
lot more sense and that's final
okay if we can prove that your movie is
bullshit will you acknowledge that ours
is better
No oh well I guess I'll just review the
movie then you do that I kind of thought
this was gonna lead to an ongoing debate
yeah like the hella comedic identities
that we could work off No well I guess
I'll just call you to if I need a
musical number seems paraffin okay fine
um here's the review the film opens with
the Chipmunks in a tree singing the song
you had a bad day a perfect tune to
foreshadow the next hour and a half pig
don't waste time developing characters
and instead cut down their house and
take it to a building in LA they're a
songwriter named Dave played by Jason
I'm still gonna see him all rats was my
biggest letdown Lee is late for an
audition
he meets up with his neighbor and
partakes in at least one of the top five
words exposition scenes ever let me
guess you're late for something again
I'm old Dave not following you guys
always fooling around you can't handle a
serious relationship you know why don't
you just turn to the camera and say hi
audience I'm Dave if you look under your
seat you'll see a trading car with my
stats on it I know it's an awkward way
to introduce you to who I am but trust
me it's much less awkward than if we
tried working it into the story we're
not really good at that talking like
humans thing but they sure are good at
ruining David Cross's career though hey
back off man
this is Dave Seville I'm still in every
year's worst movie list actually to his
credit David Cross is one of the few
genuinely funny things in this movie he
plays a music producer who clearly
doesn't give a shit that he's in a
Chipmunks movie so he gives this
delightfully passive-aggressive
performance
oh hey I love you you know what Dave
Dave Dave Dave Dave is not here
oh if they could make a doll out of this
guy I would totally buy it he sadly
though is not a fan of Dave songwriting
the original inspiration came to me song
sucks Dave what your song it's awful I
hate it
have you tried speeding it up so it
sounds like high-pitched ear penetration
I mean I need something new I need some
fresh that is a big thing I need
Christmas and hula-hoops
but Dave shows them by stealing their
muffins
yes that scene definitely needed
thrilling muffin stealing music why
don't you just play a Latin choir when
the chip might sneak into it hook out
raspberry he then proceeds to throw out
the muffins what's wrong with you those
look delicious and decides to throw out
all his music equipment to take that
free money eBay will have none of you
but don't worry he can make all they
cash back through these product
placements we can get a lot of cute
b-roll footage with these ah yeah
thought you said you weren't a baby
we're not we're on it's cute don't you
have a cat video to share or something
we don't need to we've consumed so much
cute that it's literally in our bodies
Hey look I got another one I need to
stay away from you
Dave tries to see what's going on but
apparently Alvin's fucking blond hungry
that you didn't know this will be
tolerated as much as we wish that would
happen it doesn't but he does fart in
his face oh it's funny cuz it came from
his butt they finally knock him out and
try to figure what to do with him alley
three garbage bags a shovel some
disinfectant some latex gloves and
oregano how quickly came up with that
Theodore I can't go back to prison did
you have to kill that prostitute before
Alvin she wasn't a prostitute she was an
escort big difference but Dave gets up
and they introduced themselves
I'm Simon the smart one indeed Alvin the
awesomest one oh nice to meet you I
guess Theodore doesn't have any
personality traits he fell out of the
tree at birth outside of buck for verbal
abuse
it's creepy unnatural somewhat evil hey
it's the critical praises for the front
of the box so Dave being the remarkably
unlikable character that he is throws
the cute little chipmunks out
the rain now where's that puppy I want
to hit with the handle of my gun but his
heart softens when he realizes he can
make a quick buck off of them hey you
guys can sing too this is amazing
now talking didn't mean shit but now
that you can sing your of worth here's
the deal you guys sing my songs you get
to sleep here usually in the music
industry it's the other way around you
sleep here you get to sing my songs I
don't want to come home and find a bunch
of rabbits and skunks on my couch filthy
creatures they've never associate with
him Wow
animal racist much we need to build a
wall Dave oh by the way with them being
kids you ever wonder where their parents
are our plans for hippies
hey that's early the Train Canon
explained
so while trying to think of a song to be
their outlet the Chipmunks start humming
in their sleep what a plane that loves
the though yeah pretty sad when animal
snoring can write a better melody than
you can listen I think I hear my dog
vomiting oh this inspires him to write a
song but not before realizing Simon's
vision might be a little off try these
oh thank god the makers of plastic
santa's thought their toy was
nearsighted so gave them all Simon's
prescription that was so magical kind of
dumb we're gonna have food all winter so
if you start storing it it's gonna get
gross and we're gonna have rodent
at our word dick slice non-talking
rodents so they try singing the famous
Christmas song and we get to hear days
famous scream of Alvin
well that was superbly half-assed it's
one of the most famous trademarks of the
chipmunks and there's just no effort to
it in fact every time he says it he
sounds less and less angry and more like
the kid from troll 2
but then again would he expect when his
voice is beyond hoarse in this movie oh
you're sorry that's fantastic you fled
my house you're dead Oh way leave me
alone he sounds like Bob Dylan if he's
been gargling cactus covered in
sandpaper my house is always a mess
Morrow I'm gonna call the exterminator
don't go I can explain
maybe his voice got tired from going
home after every shoot and screaming
into his pillow oh do you believe I'm in
this shit I can't believe I'm in this
shit what um mr. cross you're in the
movie action get this Dave tries to show
off the singing vermin but apparently
they get stage fright because if there's
any characteristic I associate with
Alvin it stage right but it's okay
because I get him fired from his job at
an advertising firm well not because
they drew Theodore's butt on his charts
but because they spelled half the esses
backwards and the other half forward
does yeah would you choose one or the
other you wouldn't go back and forth I
think I'll just clean out my office
sounds good
I'm sure glad we paid the extra money
for Jane Lynch in that role though to be
fair that is a very sexy chart get out
of here dumb things seem even worse at
home Theodore did you just it's a raisin
Dave prove it where's Alvin yeah Alvin
you owe me big time
chipmunks eating shit that's what I
wanted to see isn't it what you want to
see high paid good money to see Alvin
and the Chipmunks eating shit what's
going on in the other film right now oh
look at that The Chipettes are battling
sharks in Bermuda and the Chipmunks are
almost eaten alive by crocodiles what do
we got in this movie chipmunks eating
shit yes yes yes yes
you know maybe marketing wanted to train
kids into eating crap before actually
selling it to them the fine thing is in
the trailer it's shown as Alvin who eats
the turd instead of Simon that means
Alvin must have been so pissed off at
this scene that he refused to have it in
the movie
okay Simon you're up I don't know if I'm
comfortable with it ah you don't get
paid as much as Alvin you want to see
what I can really do to you proudly et
shiver user but Dave's neighbor calls
about her date hi Dave its Clare Wilson
calling and oh why did I just say my
last name
that was weird um I guess I'm just a
little nervous about coming over for
dinner I'll be there at 7:00 okay bye
Wow even for literally a phoned-in line
that was really a phoned-in line
the only thing sounding less interested
than her on the phone is her in real
life please I'm begging you
no games no fooling around no acting
either I want to stay out of the squeak
walls as much as possible my life is
being sabotaged by talking chipmunks uh
mr. Lee that's not in the script
I know I'm just making a declaration
feeling bad the chickens convinced the
producer that he dropped acid as that's
the only way he would agree to sign them
to a record recording deal as opposed to
donate them to science that video of
your little guys 10 million hits already
on YouTube it's blowing up bigger than
that gem twat
you
so much shipments start recording albums
and make Dave all sorts of money
it's a shame money can't buy love though
at least not a butt-hole like Dave's
love make sure we understand each other
here I'm not your daddy
yeah blah well not really I'm more of a
piss on a child's heart kind of person
the kind that the plot says should be
your father but anyone with the brain is
like he's an insensitive asshole they go
and perform witch doctor in front of
they clearly paid to look interested
crowd yeah I can fake having fun to this
as the film continues to show that it
doesn't need a witch doctor as much as a
script doctor I'm covering your rise to
fame I'm sorry about that night I really
thought that you and I was insane I
didn't know you were gonna be famous I
totally would have put up with all the
non-commitment stuff I talked about
earlier if I knew that and it looks like
Dave is still okay with being a douche
you're like a family who doesn't want a
family you know why don't you guys go
and play or raid the dessert table or
something I'm still not convinced you're
not a leftover hi from My Name Is Earl I
can't love when I don't know it's really
there but cross is excited to get the
merchandise going it's Alvin that looks
nothing like Alvin well then it's a
perfect toy to represent the movie I
gotta expand the Munks fan base forget
about the music the music is but a means
to the big money okay if we could put
away a nickel every time a movie says
being an advertising sellout is bad
while being an advertising sellout we
could feed all the people of the world
twice so crust looks them in the eye and
tell them that they'd all be better off
with him then we see tries looking them
in the eye
he's over there crust he's over there
look down look down cross to your left
to your left
was there a shortage of steaks with
tennis balls on them Dave's holding you
back you know
I could be making you 20 large a day you
guys will be so big that one day we'll
go up against Star Wars
yeah and beat them really yeah yeah
so cross gets them everything they
always wanted including an attractive
housemaid she's also want to see
okay first of all kid
second of all chipmunk suitable I don't
want to think of a kid shimma getting a
happy ending
I'm not simply just combining the first
two but I such a big one I thought it is
not repeating causing Dave to act even
more like duck shit for me well if you
love uncle Ian so much and you don't
think I'm watching out for you
why don't you go live with Uncle Ian so
they go live with Uncle Ian I told you
Dave I never lose wait till you see the
ways I try to sabotage chipwrecked Q
that TV is b-roll footage okay
in the other film they be singing in the
ruins of Rome not stealing whatever tune
is popular at the time but instead
singing a new rockin song how is this
any better you don't understand
cute anything in a toy monster truck
equals three adorable x' and one
precious wait there's a formula to this
stay out of this Michael Bay well I've
been targeting the wrong demographic
I've been making kids films this whole
time you may transformers those are kids
films oh no no that was my most adult
work deep Wang is very symbolic but I
really want to get crack at this chip
look for me let's see all three of them
blow up
oh dear I'm not very good at this but
Dave realizes he misses the plot and
should probably admit that he was a
horse's taint the whole time which is
good because cross was almost gonna send
the Chipmunks on an extra-long tour of
Europe oh no that'd be awful I dare even
say entertaining but on top of that it
looks like their voices are giving out
from being worked too hard you three
sound like you've been gargling nails
hey don't talk about Jason Lee that way
so he recommends that they pull a Milli
Vanilli lip-sync isn't that like
cheating no it's not like cheating this
is more like helping it's like buying
the rights to a song speeding it up and
then selling it to you again
totally not cheating but Dave tries to
sneak in and call to them Alvin
I heard that faint yell not really
louder than the last faint yell whoa
wardrobe malfunction
cover those with some Janet Jackson
nipples would you show some shame
so the Chipmunks decide to sabotage the
concert come on let's put all these
singers and dancers out of a job that'll
show the guy who already has a ton of
money unemployment line is that way poor
musicians but apparently kidnapping the
talent is legal now as Krauss throws him
in a cage and plans to still send them
on their tour I'm sure this camera tilt
down to the dolls means nothing they
just ruined the concert no one will come
to see them Dave they're Chipmunks who
talk people will come it's not what the
producers say every time they pitch a
sequel so they get to their vehicles and
partake in a thrilling climax or they
want to just end us as quickly as we do
of course I came back we're a family
ah am I going crazy or does he just say
funnel I know you kill trip me into
saying it just like a real functioning
unit I really missed you guys I missed
you too Dave so did Alvin he's just too
cool to admit it yeah because that was
the personality trait I clearly got from
him macho in fact I just realized from
movie called Alvin and the Chipmunks
Alvin has little to no personality which
is strange because he was always the
biggest personality out of all of them
he was egotistical a schemer delusional
that he was the best even though he
still had a good heart
this one was apparently not so as macho
as this piece of paper is which I've
suddenly decided to call macho so that
automatically makes it macho could you
say how this macho piece of paper you're
too macho that's so something you would
say so they drive home and Dave's poor
car reflective of his humble income to
his gigantic IKEA house worthy of any
home furnishing magazine where Alvin
again screws up
oops not gonna say it please do the
credits are right around the corner
you're still not gonna say it nope you
are holding us hostage until you do
please save the finger neither really
that good at saying I'm gonna say it oh
they're gone before you can even finish
it so yeah
this movie's brave man is it the worst
no the jimin's are pretty cute and you
get a laugh sometimes but they just
needed to be in a better script this is
every dumb Rockstar story for kids that
they for some reason think kids never
catch on - and judging by how many
sequels they've made maybe they're right
but kids deserve better stories and
characters and time devoted to giving
them something creative and exciting
this is just a planned mesh compared to
what we could have gotten and I'm sorry
the original Chipmunks movie is so much
better it's exciting weird funny
visually interesting has original songs
in it and is fun traveling the world and
giving kids an adventure this is just
gem with three hairy testicles yeah
whatever your movie makes no sense and
is incredibly dated holds up better than
your piece of crap oh yeah
what do you want to bet we get out
chipmunk movie you
oh no if they find out our films are
inferior our squeak holes will be
demolished to the ruins of franchises
hey could you give me some advice on
that kids movie formula
I like
in the past world
then again
cuz we're the real chance
where's your sequins you know
now
addresses in the 1980
oh yeah cater to your Adam Sandler
watches you're used to shut up kiss
foreskins and we'd rather be corny but
imaginative and a literal shit-eating
man what we have to
that's create
you're CG
so small lots of all you can get
cuz we're the real Chipmunks movie
you're written by Jack gasps is looking
for a chair when you got is a board
Jason Lee
keep acting like kids are dumb
jeez
meals make us the real shit mom's movie
songs we don't steal with mass appeal
make us the real chitlins movie
cuz we're the real chipmunks
while touching box
- moans mummy
crossover with the real chill
the real
and Long's movie
you
oh yeah we're the real
well that in no way determined to
anything yes was such a competitive song
nothing was really accomplished didn't
he do something like this before did
somebody say something about doing stuff
before
how have we never talked
you
hey mommy sandy without a nigga you know
what Dave Dave Dave Dave Dave is not
here
hey guys dog walker here doing the
charity shout on this week we are doing
PetSmart Charities this is a nonprofit
organization helping save homeless pets
as the leading funder of animal welfare
organizations across North America they
help save over 6.7 million pets and
Counting for adoption as well as
increased spay and neuter services
reducing pet overpopulation and joined
forces with over 3,000 animal welfare
organizations to help save as many lives
as possible
their goal is to find a lifelong loving
home for every pet finding more than
400,000 pets every year with millions of
pets still in need of homes they
continue to find new ways to reduce the
homeless population if you check out
their website or their YouTube channel
you can see all the love and caring that
you can help these people continue with
so many animals need our help and we can
do our part to make sure they're kept
safe click on the link put your paw and
check it out
you